[Music]  certainly had to battle the rumors but  how is your relationship going and are  there any wedding updates I hate to  break it to you we have no wedding  update and go um but things are going  well I feel like we're in a really good  place we're having fun we a lot of  people have been asking like how is life  slow down and it hasn't really slowed  down but we both feel a lot less  stressed I feel like we're just living  life and enjoying it and traveling just  as much but for some reason there's just  not this the stress I think we're  finally adapted we've adapted to this  like new lifestyle and where we've  learned a lot about each other we've  learned what to do what not to do what  makes each other mad what make sure  they're happy so I feel like we finally  are not like just really in a solid  solid place and a good place to maybe  start some wedding planning